J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK, so we're
finishing up on talking about
aromatic compounds, about the
chemistry of benzene.
You know, this was a big deal in
the 19th century, in part
because you had reactions
that were clean.
The compounds were often robust
and easy to purify,
crystalize, and so on.
So many of the early
developments in organic
chemistry, especially in the
second half of the 19th
century, had to do with aromatic
chemistry.
Nowadays that we have more
versatile techniques for
analyzing things like NMR and
for separating things, various
kinds of chromatography, it's
possible to work on a much
wider variety of molecules.
So much recent chemistry is on
other subjects, but much of
the classical work was on
aromatic compounds, and they
still are important.
So the Friedel Crafts reaction
we were just beginning with,
and we'll talk today about some
ideas about how you
design syntheses, and about
benzylic stabilization, the
reactivity at positions next to
an aromatic system.
And about triphenylmethyl, which
was a particularly
important compound for the
development of chemistry in
the U.S. So a subtext of what
we're talking about today is
how chemistry developed in the
United States.
Because, as we mentioned last
time, James Mason Crafts was
an American, but almost all--
essentially all his important
work was done in France and
published in French--
almost all of it.
So although he was an American,
many people thought
he was French.
You remember he started working
in Wurtz's lab,
essentially as a graduate
student-- although he wasn't
enrolled as a student, I don't
believe.
And met his seven-year-older
colleague, a student--
the first student of Wurtz-- in
that lab.
And they published a number of
papers together.
Then he published nothing at
Cornell and MIT--
that was a textbook.
And then he came back to Paris
and published this enormous
number of papers, 100 papers in
17 years, almost all of
them with Friedel.
And in particular, that paper-or
that set of papers-- in 1877,
which was the
Friedel-Crafts reaction.
Now how did they get into that?
They got into that because they
had been students
together with Wurtz.
And when he came back to work in
Friedel's lab, it was
natural that they should follow
up on the kinds of
things they were doing at that
time, on the kind of thing
that Wurtz was interested in.
So seven years before that
timeline started, Wurtz
published a paper on a new class
of radicals.
Bear in mind this is 1855, so
this is just before Couper and
Kekulé got the idea of valence.
So this was when types and
radicals were competing.
So Wurtz was in France, and he
wrote this in his thing about
a special reaction of iodides
with sodium.
And if we translate that into
modern atomic weights, it's
ethyl iodide and butyl iodide
reacting with sodium to give
ethyl butyl.
Those are his new class of
radicals.
So hexane plus two sodium
iodide.
Now, this is the infamous Wurtz
reaction.
You hear about the Wurtz
The main place you hear about
Wurtz reaction is on exam
papers of elementary organic
students, who figure you can
make any carbon-carbon bond by
taking two halides and
treating them with sodium.
But this is a horrid reaction.
It gives terrible yields.
It was possible for him to do
this, because the products
were often gaseous,
but it was not at all a high
yield reaction, because you get
a lot of cross over.
You can get ethyl with ethyl,
you can get butyl with butyl.
You can get radical reactions,
you can also get ionic
reactions of the ethyl sodium
and butyl iodide.
It's a mess.
So the question that occurred to
these guys in 1877 was,
might other metals work better?
In particular, how about
aluminum?
So they tried reacting alkyl
halide, alkyl chloride with
aluminum, with the idea of
getting R2
and aluminum chloride.
That would be an analogous
reaction
with a different model.
The question is, does it work?
And of course, they were
chemists.
They did chemistry.
And chem is try, as they said.
So they tried it.
So what they found was, it
didn't give a very good yield
of what they wanted.
It gave a lot of HCl.
And notice that that's very
different, it's not the metal
that's reacting with the
chloride, it's the hydrogen.
Where did the hydrogen come
from?
And there was lots of that.
There were as many moles of HCl
as there were of the alkyl
halide to begin with.
But very little aluminum
chloride and very
little of the R2.
Now when they tried to distill
this stuff so they didn't get
the gas, but when they tried to
distill they found higher
boiling stuff, and it was poor
in hydrogen, when
they analyzed it.
That means that it had a lot of
double bonds in it, or
rings, or both.
So they decided it was actually
benzene with R groups
attached to it.
Where did the benzene come from?
Where did the hydrogen come
from?
From the solvent.
Benzene.
And an interesting thing about
the aluminum:
they found that they reaction
was initially very slow.
But the rate depended on how
much aluminum
chloride there was.
As the reaction went on, you got
a little
bit of aluminum chloride.
And the more you got, the faster
it went, until indeed,
it was almost impossible to
control the reaction.
Although it started very
fast[correction: slow].
So they began to wonder
whether aluminum had anything to
do with it, or whether it
was just aluminum chloride.
And they decided that was true,
they didn't need aluminum,
just aluminum chloride.
So this is completely different
from what they set out to
study, it's not a Wurtz type
reaction at all, it's
completely different.
You have to rearrange things.
It's an aluminum chloride
catalyzed reaction of RCl with
an aromatic compound.
It's an aromatic substitution.
A carbon radical goes on in
place of
hydrogen, onto the benzene.
So it's a completely different
kind of substitution from what
they had set out to study.
But notice that it's rather
analogous to the idea of
chlorine reacting with catalysis
by trichloro
aluminum that we looked at last
time, where the trichloro
aluminum helps make the Cl minus
a leaving group.
So it looks like it could be the
same deal.
Of course, this was mystery to
them.
This is much later insight about
what the mechanism is.
But it's the same idea with RCl
instead of ClCl.
And it's even possible that you
can get SN1 versions of this,
where the AlCl3 pulls off
chloride and you have R plus,
if the R plus is sufficiently
stable.
Ok, so they published this first
paper in 1877.
The title of it was "On a New
General Method for
Synthesizing Hydrocarbons,
Ketones, etc." So a new
way to form a carbon-carbon
bond. So you could have RCl
and an aromatic compound react
in the catalysis by AlCl3, and
get the substituted benzene and
HCl.
Now, they say it's general, so
they tried a number of
different things.
They tried R radicals that had
one, two, and five carbons.
In this very first paper, just a
couple pages, they say they
took about five weeks to do all
this work that
I'm telling you about.
They also used bromide and
iodide, it
worked as well as chloride.
They used toluene as well as
benzene.
In fact, toluene was better
because they could get if
purer to begin with.
So they said they could do it--
they had a system
where they could keep the
thing warm and methyl chloride
bubbling through--
that's a gas--
night and day.
So they ran it for a long time,
for several days-- they
don't say exactly how many--
at 80 degrees.
And, of course, you could do a
substitution
of methyl for hydrogen.
You could do a second, a third,
a fourth, a fifth.
So from this, they got
pentachloro
and hexachloro benzene.
Both of these were new
compounds.
So a new synthetic method means
a brand new compound.
So no one had ever seen these
before.
How did they know what they had?
Well, in the case of the
hexachloro benzene, they were
able to prepare several hundred
grams this way.
Its melting point was 164,
nowadays we say it's 165, so
they had very good stuff.
They measured the molecular
weight and they got the
correct value within 2%, by
measuring the
density of the vapor.
But a strongly confirmatory
observation was that they
could oxidize it.
They tried a number of methods
of oxidation, but the one that
gave a good yield was to treat
it with cold potassium
permanganate for two months.
So that wasn't done in the five
weeks.
But they were able to get the
hexacarboxylic acid, which
remarkably enough had been known
since 1799.
Of course, in 1799 they didn't
know its structure.
They didn't know from structure
altogether until 1858.
But Baeyer had recently shown
that this compound,
which was isolated pure in 1799,
was hexacarboxylic acid of
benzene.
Incidentally, the source of it
in nature is a natural mineral
called honeystone, which is this
stuff.
It comes in nature, probably
from oxidizing graphite or
something like that, I don't
know where
it comes from exactly.
But once you make a known
product, then you know what
this new stuff is.
But the important thing was that
they were able to make
completely new compounds, and
make old compounds in new,
more efficient ways.
So this was alkylation.
It's Friedel-Crafts alkylation,
putting an alkyl
group onto benzene.
So there were other alkylations.
They found out they could use an
alkyl group that had a
benzene on it already, like
benzyl chloride here, could
react with benzene to give
diphenylmethane.
That was already known that this
was a
good way to make it.
Or they could use chloroform and
put three benzenes on it,
and get triphenylmethane.
And that was also known.
But what was new, was that they
could use carbon
tetrachloride and do one
substitution, then another,
then another, then another and
get tetraphenylmethane, which
was an unknown compound.
In fact, it wasn't even known
then, because it turned out
that wasn't what they had,
although it's what
they said they had.
Because it's hard to know these
things.
It wasn't that, because it's too
crowded to try to get four
phenyl groups on a single
carbon.
So it only did three
substitutions, not four.
And it was the triphenylmethyl
chloride, but it didn't have
chlorine anymore, because they
worked it up with water.
And the water changed the
chloride into
an OH, an SN1 reaction.
But that was a new compound for
them.
But they found that if you used
phenyl chloride--
chlorobenzene--
if the chlorine was on the
benzene ring,
then it didn't react.
So it wasn't perfectly general.
But it could use alkyl or
aralkyl, that
is phenyl on a carbon.
So you could have benzyl, but
you couldn't
have aryl as the group.
But then notice that they also
said it could be used to make
ketones, how to make a ketone
that way.
So you start with a chloride
that already has a C=O in it,
an acid chloride.
And when they reacted benzoyl
chloride with benzene, they
got diphenyl ketone, which was a
known compound.
But this was a better way to
make it.
With acetyl chloride, they could
get a
phenylmethyl ketone.
That was a known compound.
Here was an interesting one.
With a diacid chloride, the
phthaloyl chloride,
they could get a compound which,
I think, was unknown at that
time with two
phenyl groups put on.
So it could react twice.
Or it could react twice with the
same benzene
molecule to give that.
And that was a compound that was
known, anthraquinone.
So they could get ketones, as
well alkyl.
So this is a very, very general
reaction.
Very important for synthesis.
So you could use acyl as well as
alkyl.
So you have not only
Friedel-Crafts alkylation,
but Friedel-Crafts acylation to
made ketones.
What is the question mark, what
compound do you need to
do a Friedel-Crafts reaction to
get that compound?
Name the question mark.
Liang, what would you use?
STUDENT: Propane with a
chlorine.
PROFESSOR: 1-chloropropane or
n-propyl chloride.
That compound.
So does it work?
We'll try.
A warning.
Remember that once you put one
alkyl group on--
we talked about last time-- it
becomes more reactive.
So there's going to be a
problem.
If the product is 25 times as
reactive as the starting
material, then you're going to
get higher substitution
instead of being able to get a
good yield of what you want.
But the good news was that if it
was done for five hours
with aluminum chloride-- this
was done by Ipatieff in 1940--
he was able to get about a 45%
yield up monosubstitution.
Now when you read "yield," you
often wonder what it means.
Naïvely, you say you get 45% as
many moles of the product
as you have of starting
material.
That's what you'd read that,
naïvely.
But that's not what they meant.
Because if you used up half the
starting material, so at
the latter stages you have
nearly as much of this as you
do of the starting benzene,
and this stuff is reacting 25
times faster-,
there's no way you're going to
get a 45% yield.
So what they mean is 45% of the
product is mono as opposed
to di-, tri-, tetrasubstituted.
So in fact, probably only about
15% of
the benzene was consumed.
But still, they could get half
of the product was
monosubstitution at that point.
OK, that's great.
But the bad news is that of the
monosubstitution, it's not
just the compound that Liang
wanted to make.
It's 60% of that and 40% of the
one we wanted.
Now that was done... So that you
could have rearrangement during
the Friedel-Crafts alkylation.
Now that was done at a slightly
warm temperature.
If they did it at -6 degrees,
then it turned around
and you got more of the compound
you wanted.
But still, there's rearrangement
somehow.
How does the rearrangement
occur?
Well, remember the aluminum
chloride comes up and starts
pulling off the chloride and
makes a complex like this with
the incipient cation.
You wouldn't expect the primary
cation to
form easily, right?
But you've the aluminum attached
there, so it's
beginning to develop a charge.
But that thing that you see
there, that complex, can react
with the benzene.
That is, benzene comes in and
displaces the AlCl4.
So you get the intermediate with
both H and the n-propyl
attached to the same carbon,
that cation.
And then you lose the proton and
you've got the product--
one of the products.
But the other product comes,
because--
so that gives the n-propyl
benzene.
But there's a hydrogen here.
And so what else can happen when
you start pulling the
chloride away?
STUDENT: Hydride shift.
PROFESSOR: You can get a hydride
shift.
Bingo.
So the hydride goes there, the
cation moves to the middle,
and now you get the other
product.
But notice if you do it cold, if
you do at -6
degrees, you get more of the
initial reaction before the
hydride shift occurs.
So it's possible to get the
product you want, at least a
substantial amount of it.
But you have to be worried about
rearrangement if the
cation that you're trying to put
on is one that could
rearrange to a more stable
cation.
How about if you wanted to make
acylation?
There, you don't get
rearrangement.
Why not?
Because when you're making this
cation, it's stabilized
by an unshared pair on the
oxygen.
So it doesn't rearrange.
It's already the most stable
cation you can get from that.
So with acylation, you don't get
rearrangement.
But you need one equivalent, not
just a catalytic amount, of
aluminum trichloride, because it
gets eaten up by the
product, by associating with the
carbonyl group-- and by
the starting material, as well
actually.
But it complexes that way, as
well.
But even though you've got a lot
of aluminum chloride in
there, you can easily get rid of
it just by adding water
once you have the product.
So now you have this
unrearranged ketone.
But suppose what you really
wanted in your heart of
hearts, Liang, was not the
ketone.
You wanted propyl benzene.
Ah, that's what you want.
How can you get there?
By removing the O and replacing
it with H2.
And there are reagents for doing
that.
Like the Clemmensen reduction,
treat with the zinc and
hydrochloric acid.
Now that's a very strong acidic
medium, so maybe other
things in your compound wouldn't
stand up to it.
Propyl benzene is one thing, a
more complicated molecule is
something else.
Maybe the thing you want won't
tolerate acid, but it will
tolerate base.
Then you could use the
Wolff-Kishner reduction, with
hydrazine and potassium
hydroxide.
But notice it's done at 200
degrees, so that's a very
vigorous thing.
And, if neither of these work--
both of them are cheap
and give good yields--
but if neither of them work,
there are other reagents
nowadays that you could use.
Those are the classical reagents
for changing the acyl
to an alkyl.
But the important thing to see
here is that you've now been
able to make that compound
without worrying about the
rearrangement, by going by way
of the ketone.
So that's a synthetic strategy.
So let's think about what things
you can get from
benzene, what groups you can put
on using aromatic
substitutions that we talked
about last time, and also the
alkyl and acyl Friedel-Crafts
reactions.
We said you could put deuterium
on with D2SO4.
Chlorine on with chlorine and
AlCl3, or bromine
with bromine and FeBr3.
Or other metal salts could work
as well, these so-called
Lewis acids.
Or you could use the
Friedel-Crafts acylation
and make a ketone,
or alkylation and make
an alkyl compound-- as long as
it doesn't rearrange.
Or you could even put CO on HCl.
HCl will protonate CO to make
the cation that then puts on
HC=O as a substitution reaction.
So that one would work too.
Or you could put a nitro group
on, we said, with nitric acid,
sometimes with sulfuric acid, if
you need
it to be more reactive.
Or you could put on SO3H, that
is SO3 can get protonated by
sulfuric acid and then the HSO3
can go on and give these
sulfonic acid products.
So there are lots of different
things you can put on
benzene this way.
And in fact, the sulfonic acid
can come off again, the SO3 can
come off again if you treat it
very hot with steam.
And you might wonder, why would
you do that if you went
to all the work to put it on?
And you'll see shortly why that
is.
You can also get other compounds
by changing these
groups into something else.
For example, the nitro group.
You can reduce it, either
catalytically with palladium
or by using a reagent and a
metal, like tin and HCl and
get aniline, the aminobenzene.
So NO2 can become NH2.
And then you could treat NH2
with nitrous acid.
It's sodium nitrite and HCl.
The HCl protonates it, you get
nitrous acid.
And that changes NH2 into N2
plus, which is called
a diazonium compound,
benzenediazonium chloride,
that's called.
Now why in the world would you
make that?
Well, it has a resonance
structure here that has plus
on the nitrogen.
And that can be the cation that
does substitution,
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
And notice that you're making it
in the presence of
something that's a very active
receptor for that.
So you could make this compound,
which is important
because it's yellow.
It's a yellow dye.
It's called aniline yellow, and
it was the first such dye
that was made;
the first of hundreds of these
so-called azo dyes that
are all different colors.
I looked it up on the web to see
if I could get a picture
of something dyed with it, and
find that it's very popular
for skateboards nowadays, to use
aniline yellow.
But hundreds of these were made.
This was where activity was in
organic chemistry.
This was before synthetic drugs.
This was before plastics.
This was before the use of
petroleum the
way it's used nowadays.
So there weren't these
commercial driving forces for
developing organic chemistry.
But dyes were important.
So the last half of the 19th
century there was a lot of
work on things like this.
So hundreds of these were
developed.
And they have fancy names.
Like Bismarck brown, named after
the Iron
Chancellor of Germany.
It was a brown color.
And in fact, notice that there
were two of these reactions that
went on to give this
Bismarck brown.
It made two of these azo groups
in there.
I looked up Bismarck brown on
the web, and find out that
it's used as a histological
stain.
There it is.
So this was a big deal.
But that's not the only reason
that these diazonium chloride
was important.
N2 is a fabulous leaving group.
The N-N triple bond is the
strongest diatomic bond.
So it very easily leaves as N2.
And notice that that's a very
clean reaction, too.
When it leaves, what does it
leave behind if you lose N2
from benzene diazonium cation?
It's the phenyl cation.
A cation that's very hard to
make.
Because, we talked about that
before, it's a very strong bond
and not a good place to have a
vacancy, in
an sp squared orbital.
So there are lots of synthetic
uses for the diazonium
chloride besides making dyes.
So you can treat it with HBr and
copper bromide,
cuprous bromide, CuBr,
to put a bromine on in place of
N2.
Or chlorine on in place, or
cyanide on in place of N2.
Now all these reactions called
Sandmeyer reactions, after the
guy who developed the idea of
using the copper bromide,
probably go first by an electron
transfer.
So you have CuBr2 minus, Which
is formed from Br minus plus
the copper bromide.
So that gives an electron to one
of the antibonding
orbitals in nitrogen.
So you generate this radical
instead of the cation, and a
radical from the copper reagent.
But that's very unstable, and it
loses
nitrogen instantly, N2.
So you have that radical.
But now these radicals react
with one another to put the
bromine on.
You have copper bromide, which
then adds bromide minus again,
and recycles.
So the copper is catalytic.
So you could do it also with
chlorine, also with cyanide.
You could do it with iodide.
You don't even need the copper
there, because I minus itself
can give the electron to the
diazonium compound.
You could do it with BF4 minus,
which is probably different.
That's probably not donation of
electron.
That one probably does involve
losing N2 from the cation to
form the phenyl cation, which
then pulls off a
fluoride from BF4 minus.
So that's probably an SN1
reaction, where N2 leaves.
It's a great leaving group.
And probably the same for the
reaction with
water, to put OH on.
You could also react it with
NaNO2 to put NO2 on.
But what's the utility of that?
Why would you want to do that?
Is that going to be, you think,
a way you're going to
make your fortune?
To sell nitrobenzene making it
this way?
What's the problem?
Yeah?
STUDENT: The NO2 is a cation?
PROFESSOR: No, that's not the
problem.
The NO2 here is an anion.
NaNO2 is an anion.
We talked about NO2 plus before,
but this is NO2 minus.
So this would do the trick.
But commercially, this is bound
to fail.
Matt?
MATT: You used that to get the
diazonium.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Remember, where
did we get the diazonium salt?
We got it from the amine.
Where did we get the amine?
We got it from the nitro group.
So we could run our factory day
and night and turn
starting material into product
at pretty good yield.
But you're not going to make a
fortune that way.
But there is utility for that,
but it's not obvious at first.
And the same thing is true here.
You can react with
hypophosphorous acid, H3PO,
not phosphoric acid,
and that puts H on, instead of
the N2.
But that's going even further
back to benzene.
Why in the world would you want
to do that?
Well, we'll show you what's the
utility of that one?
Now suppose you want to prepare
a certain compound,
like para-nitrochlorobenzene.
How are you going to make it?
Well, you can start with
nitrobenzene.
And we know how to put a
chlorine on.
How do you put chlorine on?
What reagent do you use to put
chlorine on?
What, in general, to put any X
on in place of H, what form of
X do you need?
What's the thing that does the
attacking?
X what?
X radical?
X minus?
X plus?
It's electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
You need X plus.
So if we want to put chlorine
in, we need chlorine plus.
Where do we get chlorine plus?
Cl2 plus AlCl3.
AlCl3 pulls the chloride off, we
have the equivalent of Cl
plus, and that'll do the trick.
Except it won't do the trick.
Why?
Why won't this work?
We talked about it last time.
Because nitro is deactivating.
It'll make the reaction slow,
but still it'll happen.
But not only is it deactivating,
what else is it?
Metadirecting.
It's not going to give this
product, it's going to give
the meta product.
So are we out of luck?
Is there a way of making the
parachloronitrobenzene?
How would you do it?
Sebastian?
STUDENT: Start with the Cl.
PROFESSOR: Start--
so that one's not going to work.
But start with the--
because you'd get the wrong
isomer.
But if you start with the Cl and
put the nitro on, now the
reaction is more reactive.
Nitro is a very strong reactive
reagent.
And chloro is ortho/para
directing, so you're going to
get the compound you want.
Great.
Now suppose what you want is
meta-chlorophenol,
hydroxybenzene?
That's the one you want to make.
So how are we going to do that?
Now because both O and Cl are
ortho/para-directing, so we
can't decide which one we're
going to put on.
Furthermore, we don't have the O
plus reagent to put O on.
We have the Cl plus reagent, but
we don't
have the O plus reagent.
So how are we going to get these
things in the meta position?
Well, we could put the chlorine
on.
Remember, at least we got meta
things by that
mistake we made before.
And now if we could convert
nitro to OH, then we've got the
product we want.
Any way of getting OH?
Those of you with rapid
photographic memories?
You convert nitro to amine.
I think you can reduce it with
this reagent.
I'm not sure.
But if not that one, there'll be
another one that allows you
to reduce it.
Then HONO converts it to the
diazonium, and water converts
that to OH.
So we were able to do it that
way by way of the nitro group.
Converting the diazonium
compound to OH,
the diazonium salt.
Or you could also make it a
halogen there, or a nitrile,
or NO2, or H. But of course, if
it were NO2, you could do
it a different way.
Now why would you want to do H
to make chlorobenzene?
That seems stupid.
So the key reaction here is
HONO, nitrous acid, for
converting aniline, the amino
benzene into any of many
different things.
Here's a picture of the Yale
chemistry class, Sheffield
Scientific School in 1898.
So a lot of distinguished
looking guys sitting here.
And they're showing the tools of
their trade, as we
mentioned before.
But there's a little box at the
feet of the guy who's
playing a flask like a banjo,
here.
And do you see what it says on
it?
Hot or cold, OH NO!
So this is a little pun here.
It's HONO.
Because this is the chemistry
they were doing at that time.
Making diazonium things and
converting
one thing to another.
So suppose what you want to do
is convert toluene into
1,3,5-trimethylbenzene.
What's the problem?
Just do Friedel-Crafts and put
methyl groups on, right?
What's wrong with that?
The alkyl groups are ortho/para
directing, you
won't get this isomer.
If you try that, it's going to
fail.
But you could put nitro group on
in the para position.
We already talked about that
kind of thing with chlorine
instead of methyl as an
ortho/para director.
And now what are we going to do?
We've got not only the wrong
group, nitro instead of
methyl, but we've got it in the
wrong place.
But this is an indirect
synthesis.
Notice what you can do is reduce
it, the nitro to amine.
And now you could react that.
Or if it's too reactive--
remember that the rocket fuel
was a nitration of something
like that--
you could acetylate it, if
that's necessary.
I don't know whether it would
be.
And now you do the
Friedel-Crafts reaction.
Now this is ortho/para
directing, methyl, so it would
tend to put it here or here.
But this is more strongly
ortho/para directing because
of the unshared pair.
And it would put it here or
here.
So it's a stronger ortho/para
director than the methyl is,
that unshared pair.
So it goes to there.
So now you have that NH2 group
there.
So we've got the methyls where
we want them, but
we've got an NH2.
What are you going to do about
that?
What do we convert NH to?
What did the people in 1898S do?
They treated it with HONO.
Make the diazonium salt and then
react that with
hypophosphorous acid to convert
it to hydrogen.
So the nitro, then the amino
group was put on in order to
direct where other things are
going.
And then you have to take it off
again.
So there was a utility to
removing it with hydrogen.
Now here's a problem for you to
work on.
How to make para dinitrobenzene
with the
reactions that we know about
here.
So you can work on that on your
own.
Now here's an interesting
compound.
2, 4-dinitrofluorobenzene.
And the interesting thing about
that one is it reacts
within an amine to replace
fluorine by the amine.
So this is an aromatic
substitution.
But it's different from the ones
we've been talking about.
Can you see why?
Why it's not like the
electrophilic aromatic
substitutions we've been talking
about?
What makes the nitrogen
reactive?
Arvind? What makes the nitrogen
reactive of the amine?
STUDENT: It has a partially
negative charge, right?
PROFESSOR: Well it's a little
negatively charged,
what's its high HOMO?
STUDENT: The unshared pair.
PROFESSOR: Unshared pair.
So that's what's going to make
it reactive.
Now we have nucleophilic
aromatic substitution.
The things we've been talking
about
before are plus reagents.
Cl plus, carbon plus, NO2 plus.
This is high HOMO instead of a
low LUMO.
Now that product actually is
important to make it yellow.
Because it was used when you do
chromatography, if you
spray it with this stuff, where
the amines
are will turn yellow.
So it's a good visualization
reagent.
And it identifies the amino acid
at the end of a chain,
because if you put this on the
end of the chain where there's
NH2 and then cleave it apart and
see what the pieces are,
the one that's yellow was the
one that was on
the end of the chain.
So this stuff was called
Sanger's reagent, after
Frederick Sanger, who used it to
determine the amino acid
sequence of insulin.
In fact, he invented this way of
doing it, putting this
color label on and he sequenced
insulin in 1955.
And three years later, he got
the Nobel Prize for this,
Sanger did.
Incidentally, how do people know
the
sequence of proteins nowadays?
Do they do it this way?
Do you know?
How do people know what the
sequence of a
protein is going to be?
They do it by sequencing the
nucleic acid, right?
And in fact, Sanger got the 1980
Nobel Prize for
sequencing DNA.
So he got two Nobel Prizes for
sequencing.
But this clever thing, that he,
as a good chemist, figured
out how to do, is nucleophilic
aromatic substitution.
Now how is it well designed,
this reagent, to do that?
Well for one thing, it's yellow.
The product is yellow.
But another one is that this
anion that you get is very
good because it's got a nitro
group where the charge is.
Or there.
So it's activated for forming
that intermediate
by two nitro groups.
Then you lose the proton, and
then you lose fluoride.
The normal electrophilic
aromatic substitution, X plus
comes on, forming an
intermediate with plus plus
plus, and then H plus leaves.
Now something minus comes on, or
a high HOMO, the amine,
minus minus minus, and then F
minus goes away.
Now why was F such a good thing
to choose?
Because F, generally, is not
such a great leaving group.
The other halogens are better as
leaving groups.
It's good because the leaving is
not the rate determining
step of this thing.
The slow step is that initial
addition.
So the more electron withdrawing
the substituent
is, the better it will be.
So fluoride is the one to use.
So it's activated by fluorine.
So Sanger, a great chemist,
figured out a good reagent and
got rewarded with a Nobel Prize.
In fact, two Nobel Prizes.
Now, another place this crops up
is in NAD plus, which is
this compound.
Have you heard of NAD plus and
NADH?
Some of you?
You will when you take
biochemistry if you haven't
heard about it yet.
These are oxidizing reducing
agents.
So you have, say, an alcohol
with a secondary alcohol so
you have an H there,
and now you can do a
nucleophilic aromatic
substitution.
Notice what's going onto the
benzene is H with the
electrons, H minus.
It's helped out by the unshared
pair on
oxygen coming in here.
And this, then, is a good place
to put the electrons, on
the nitrogen.
So you get a ketone that got
oxidized, and this NADH.
Now the nice thing is that this
is reversible.
The energies of these two are
closely enough balanced that
you can run it backwards and
forwards.
That means this reagent NAD plus
can be used as an oxidizing
reagent, NADH can be used as a
reducing agent.
So you can make an alcohol into
a ketone or a ketone into
an alcohol.
And these are key molecules in
biological
oxidation and reduction.
And notice the way they do it is
by transferring H minus,
accepting or giving back H
minus.
So that's that nucleophilic
aromatic substitution.
So benzylic reactivity was
related to pKa.
Remember, what's the pKa of
normal alkanes, roughly?
How acidic is RH?
Just a regular old alkane,
roughly?
pKa?
STUDENT: 50-something.
PROFESSOR: 50-something, 50 few.
But if you have allylic H, it's
43.
So it's something like seven
powers of 10, or nine
kilocalories better than a
normal alkyl group, because of
allylic stabilization.
If you have phenyl of
vinyl[correction: benzyl],
instead of the carbon-carbon
double bond, it's even two
powers of 10 better, or
12kcal/mole.
And if you have two phenyl
groups on it, diphenylmethane,
it's much better.
It's another 11 kilocalories
better.
Not quite as good as the first
one because there's not as
high a HOMO any more, once one
has begun to lower it.
So there's a little bit less.
Predict what it's going to be if
you put three
phenyl groups on.
Luke, you look ready to go on
making a prediction here.
How many kilocalories?
STUDENT: 10.
PROFESSOR: Another 10.
It's 3.
The third one does hardly
anything.
Why?
Because it's so crowded that the
phenyls have to twist, and
don't overlap very well.
So steric hindrance in and
triphenylmethyl reduces the
overlap with the anion you want
to stabilize, so it reduces it
by 25% from diphenylmethyl.
OK, so the crowding is an
important thing.
And this brings us to Moses
Gomberg and the
triphenylmethyl radical, which
is 110 years old
this academic year.
It was announced in October,
1900.
So October we were already
underway in this class.
So Moses Gomberg was a speaker
when this building was
dedicated in 1923, one of the
featured speakers.
But he came from a very
different
background from Crafts.
Remember Crafts was the son of
an industrialist in Boston and
could afford to go 17 years to
Paris to do his research.
But Gomberg was born in the
Ukraine.
He was Jewish and his father got
in political trouble, and
there were pogroms going on, so
he and Moses left and came
to Chicago where Moses--
he was born in '66, so here he's
18 years old, and he's
working in the stockyards in
Chicago for two years.
But then, somehow, he gets to
the University of Michigan two
years later.
And here's his transcript from
the University of Michigan.
He graduated in 1890.
So let's look at what kind of
thing you would have taken if
you were getting a BS in
chemistry, as it says up here,
at Michigan in 1890.
There were distribution classes.
So he took French, Rhetoric,
Logic, and Psychology.
And then these are science
classes, physics and math.
And here are chemistry related
classes.
There are metallurgy, scientific
freehand drawing,
geology and minerology, and
chemical literature in German
and French.
And the big one in the middle,
not too
surprisingly, is chemistry.
So the distribution wasn't quite
what it is here nowadays.
And here he is as a student in
the analytical laboratory.
After his freshman year, he
averaged nine and a half
chemistry labs a week.
That's labs, not hours in lab.
Nine and a half different lab
sessions a week.
And two-thirds of them were
analytical chemistry.
That's what he's doing, he's
doing a titration here.
So there was no spectroscopy
then.
Then after he graduated and got
his PhD--
he was I think the second PhD in
chemistry at
the University of Michigan.
And it's interesting that he
studied chemistry.
You might think as an immigrant
who had worked in
the stockyards, he would be
trying to do
some practical work.
So, in this three year period
when he was an
undergraduate, there were,
I think, something like
400 graduates in pharmacy from
Michigan and about five in
chemistry.
And he took chemistry.
So that's very interesting.
But anyhow, then he went to
learn in Germany in Munich
with Baeyer.
So there's Baeyer, 61, the head
of the lab.
And here's his assistant,
Thiele, who was 31.
And here's Richard Willstatter,
who was 24 then,
the fair-haired boy in the lab,
who got the Nobel Prize
in 1920 as an organic chemist.
And here's Moses Gomberg.
He's 30 years old, older because
of his family history
than these other people,
almost as old as Thiele.
But here's what Willstatter the
Nobel laureate,
later said about him.
Moses Gomberg was Thiele's
coworker in the student
laboratory.
He was very reserved and modest,
kept entirely to
himself, and never chatted in or
out of laboratory.
Some years later, the work he
carried out in the United
States on the triphenylmethyl
radical,
"a case of trivalent carbon
became famous."
And you know what I think the
key phrase is here?
"in the United States." Because
remember, Crafts's
work was done in France,
nothing in the United States.
But here, just two decades
later, the key work is being
done in the United States.
So we're going to see how this
happened.
"This brilliant experiment, one
of the most beautiful in
organic chemistry and one which
few people credited at
first, gave great impetus
to chemistry
and would have been worthy
of any distinction."
So he was nominated,
Gomberg was, for
the Nobel Prize a number of
times, but he never got it.
Now how did he get into this?
Well, just before he got to
the lab, Thiele, the guy in the
front row who ultimately drank
himself to death in France,
had a student named Heuser who
made this compound called
AIBN, azoisobutyronitrile.
And from it, in 50% yield,
prepared a new
carbon-carbon bond.
And this is a different way of
making carbon-carbon bonds.
The way you do it is to lose
nitrogen.
So N2 comes out and the two
radicals come together.
So when Gomberg came along into
the lab for just a
semester, or maybe two semesters
it was, he said,
"Under the sponsorship of
Professor Thiele, I have
followed up on these
reactions..."
So he worked on this compound,
this idea of
knocking nitrogen out.
And then he went for the third
term to Heidelberg to work
with Victor Meyer, who had
introduced the
idea of steric hindrance.
This was a stressful time to be
in Heidelberg because Meyer
committed suicide during this
period.
But an interesting question in
steric hindrance was this
tetraphenylmethane.
Remember, Friedel and Crafts
thought they had made
tetraphenylmethane, but in fact
they had made
triphenylmethyl chloride because
it's so crowded.
So Friedel-Crafts wouldn't make
it.
They tried with phenyl anions,
phenyl metal compounds, to
make tetraphenyl methane, and
they couldn't do it.
So this was a real challenge - a
grand challenge, was how to make
tetraphenylmethane.
Not that anybody thought it
would be good for anything,
but it was a symmetrical,
beautiful compound and how do
you make it?
And Gomberg succeeded.
"I have tried to solve this
problem in a completely
different way.
So the way he used was what he
had learned the previous two
terms in Munich.
So in Heidelberg, he tried
making this compound, which
you get from benzene diazonium
salt and triphenylmethyl
chloride, the stuff that
Friedel-Crafts could make.
So he tried it to see if it
would work, and at 110 degrees
with copper there, from eight
grams of the starting material
he got 0.3 grams of this stuff.
How does he know what it was?
Well he discusses the
solubility, but that's not a
very good key to what
the compound is.
But he did the analysis.
And this is what he found.
And this is the theoretical.
So it agreed very well with
that.
And what else might you be able
to do?
The molecular weight would be
very key.
And how do you get the molecular
weight?
You can get it from the vapor
density.
But this has very low vapor
pressure.
But you can get it by freezing
point lowering.
So that's what he did, he tried
freezing point lowering.
He had 300 milligrams of this
material and he used 100
milligrams for this purpose.
And he found that he lowered the
melting
point by 0.289 degrees.
This is real, careful work.
He's being paid off for having
spent nine and a half labs a
week for three years at
Michigan.
Oh, it's boiling point, not
freezing.
The solvent boiling point
elevation, which implied 306
for the molecular weight, and he
calculated 320.
So very good.
So then he went back to
Michigan, to Ann Arbor.
He stayed there the rest of his
life working at the
University of Michigan.
And what did he do when he got
back?
I'll tell you next time.